- Dwarf goblins.
I mean, she literally looks like a goblin.
I'm just telling you,
and acts like a goblin.
- Just because you claim
to think something is true,
does not make it true.
- The jury awards almost
50 million in damages
against Alex Jones and
his companies for defaming
the parents of children killed
in the Sandy Hook massacre.
After years of being
targeted by Alex Jones,
the parents finally had their
chance to address Jones,
to his face, in court.
And things did not go well for Jones.
Just how bad was it?
So bad that former Prosecutor
Mitchell Epner said,
"In over 25 years as a trial lawyer,
I have never seen a witness
do more damage to himself
on the stand than Alex Jones.
And that includes a case where I was AUSA,
where I got a defendant to
admit that he was guilty
of the crime charged in the indictment."
It was so bad that also, former
Prosecutor Ken White said,
"It was like an action movie
where it's not enough
that the bad guy gets shot
or stabbed at the end.
He's gotta be like decapitated
and exploded and impaled
at the same time."
But let's start at the beginning.
Why was Alex Jones on trial?
In 2012, a lone gunman murdered
six adults and 20 children
at the Sandy Hook Elementary
School in Newtown, Connecticut.
Alex Jones and his
associate, Alan Shroyer,
and Wolfgang Helbig said
that the event was a hoax
that did not happen.
- The whole thing was a giant hoax.
- The Jones gang accused
the bereaved family members
of being, quote, "crisis actors".
- And it just shows how bold they are,
that they clearly used actors.
- And Jones and his correspondence
repeated those claims
on "Infowars" broadcast.
- Okay, so just another
question that people are now
going to be asking about Sandy Hook.
- Alex Jones' fans
harassed the parents online
and at their homes.
And after several years of this,
some of the Sandy Hook families
sued Jones for defamation
in Connecticut and Texas.
During his deposition in one
of the other Sandy Hook cases,
lawyers played clips of
Jones mocking the parents
and calling their tears bad acting.
- The only problem is that I've watched
a lot of soap operas, and
I've seen actors before.
And I know when I'm watching a movie
and I know when I'm
watching something real.
- And in response to those clips,
Jones admitted under oath
that he knew his statements were false.
After his deposition Jones and "Infowars"
denied having emails, text messages,
and other material about
the Sandy Hook claims.
Jones and his lawyers
then ignored court orders
to produce documents in
Texas and Connecticut.
And spoiler alert,
during the damages trial,
we found out that they lied
about having this material
when one of his lawyers accidentally sent
Jones's entire cell phone
and a whole bunch of other
documents to opposing counsel.
- Your attorneys messed up
and sent me an entire digital copy
of your entire cell phone
with every text message
you've sent for the past two years.
- And Jones has a whole pattern
of disregarding discovery obligations
in other cases as well.
And some people have claimed that Jones
has gotten railroaded by having liability
conceded by default.
And that Jones's constitutional
rights have been infringed.
That is not the case here.
Here, it was a strategic choice
by Jones and his attorney
to not turn documents over,
all the while claiming
that they never possessed
relevant documents and that
those documents didn't exist.
We know now that that is not the case,
that it was a strategic choice
to hold those documents back,
and never turn them over
and then face the repercussions in court,
which is what they basically have done,
and why liability was conceded.
- But I'm not going to seal the entire
quantity of information
without knowing what's in it
when the rules weren't followed properly.
- And taking all of
that into consideration,
the judges in all 10
Sandy Hook cases entered
default judgements against
Jones and his companies.
A default judgment
happens when the defendant
in a civil case fails to do something,
such as ignoring court
summons, missing a court date,
or disregarding the judges direct orders.
And if this occurs, a
court may rule in favor
of the plaintiff by default.
And this is very rare.
A default judgment is
the most serious sanction
a judge can impose during a civil trial.
Judges do not enter default
judgements very often.
But if you want to learn more about why
the default judgements
were entered against Jones,
check out my video on the topic.
I have an entire video
on the predamages portion
of this trial.
But this particular case that
we're talking about today
is the first of three upcoming trials
that will decide how much
money Jones and his companies
must pay in damages.
It was filed by Neil
Heslin and Scarlett Lewis,
who are the parents of
six-year-old, Jesse Lewis,
who was killed at Sandy Hook.
And since the default
judgments were issued,
Jones couldn't contest liability.
The trial was only about
how much Jones must pay.
And the plaintiff sought $150 million
in compensatory and punitive damages.
So what did the plaintiff
say during trial?
Well, Neil Heslin was the
first plaintiff to testify.
- I can't even describe
the last 9 1/2 years
of the living hell that I
and others have had to endure
because of the negligence
and the recklessness
of Alex Jones.
- He and Lewis said that strangers
have confronted them everywhere,
including at their homes.
Heslin's house and car
have been shot by people
yelling out, "Alex Jones."
- But he drove by my home,
shouting out the window,
"Alex Jones", and sounded like gunfire
coming from the vehicle.
- Heslin gave heart-wrenching testimony
about holding his son and
seeing that he had a bullet hole
through his head.
Owen Shroyer went on Jones' program
and said that Heslin lied about
the holding his son's body.
- [Owen] I think it's time for you
to explain this contradiction
in the narrative.
- And this is apparently what
prompted Heslin and Lewis
to fight back.
- Alex started this fight,
and I'll finish this fight.
- Now, Jones wasn't in court
to hear Heslin's testimony about Jesse.
It's not necessary to show up to court,
but you know, usually
you do want to do that.
Instead, while Heslin testified,
Jones did a live show
where he called Heslin slow
and autistic and accused him
of being manipulated by lawyers.
- But I'll just say
'cause I gotta be honest,
he's slow, okay?
- This was not a good
strategy because this clip
was then played in court for
the jury just a few days later.
- I mean, I been Heslin acts
like somebody on the spectrum.
- It supported one of the
plaintiff's key claims
that Jones has spent years ridiculing
the Sandy Hook parents,
and that he can't control
himself or his employees
who continue to harass the families.
Now after court, Heslin and
Jones had a confrontation
where Jones again called
Heslin a slow person
who's being manipulated by lawyers.
Jones also ripped the judge
on his "Infowars" program.
- And they're all caricatures
of what you would imagine
in some alternate
universe of dwarf goblins.
It's demonic.
They all act demonically
possessed, the judge, the lawyers.
- Now part of our job as
lawyers is client control.
We tell our clients not to talk
about their cases in public.
Don't post a Facebook.
Don't share things in the media.
Don't talk with friends and family,
but ultimately though,
it's up to the client
to demonstrate some self-control.
- Judge Goblin here in Austin,
I mean, she literally looks like a goblin,
I'm just telling you,
and acts like a goblin.
- Even the greatest lawyers in history
would probably be powerless to stop Jones
from being himself.
And then there was the testimony
of plaintiff Scarlett Lewis.
Jones was again, not in
court for the first half
of Scarlett Lewis's testimony.
When he finally arrived,
he was accompanied by
a team of bodyguards.
Lewis addressed her
testimony directly to Jones
while he sat at the defense table.
- I am a mother first and foremost.
And I know that you're a father.
And my son existed.
I know you believe me.
And yet, you're gonna
leave this courthouse
and you're gonna say
it again on your show.
- At one point Lewis directly asked Jones-
- You think I'm an actress?
- [Alex] No, I don't think you're
an actress.
- No,
you can't talk right now.
- Sorry.
- Now Lewis told Jones
that he makes claims
about the massacre that he knows are lies.
- But when you say those things,
there's a fringe of
society that believe you,
that are actually dangerous.
- And Lewis emphasized the deep trauma
that she has because of
Jones and his followers.
- It seems so incredible to
me that we have to do this,
that we have to implore you,
not just implore you,
punish you to get you to stop lying.
- A forensic psychologist
who met Heslin and Lewis
said both suffer from a form
of post-traumatic stress disorder
that comes from constant trauma.
Jones's lawyer, Reynal, had a tough time
handling these witnesses
on cross examination
because it would be incredibly hard
to cross examine these witnesses.
At one point, he suggested
that it would be more healing
for Lewis and Heslin to sit down
and talk through their
trauma with Alex Jones
than it would to file a lawsuit.
On cross-examination,
Jones' lawyer grilled Lewis
about her finances,
noting her book contract
and speaking engagements.
- [Federico] Can you tell the
members of the jury how much
is this suggested honorarium
and for your speaking engagement?
- It may be $5,000.
- [Federico] Would 10 be more accurate?
- It could be 10.
- And he said that she makes
more than enough to pay
for her own therapy.
Now I'm gonna go out on a limb here
and say that this questioning
probably did not go over
particularly well with the jury.
And then there's the testimony
of Alex Jones himself.
When he took the stand, he told plaintiffs
that he's always wanted to apologize.
- That I never intentionally
tried to hurt you.
I never even said your name
until this case came to court.
I didn't even really know who you were
until a couple years ago
when all this started up.
The internet had a lot of questions.
I had questions.
- Jones argued that he
made a few inquiries
about whether Sandy Hook
was a false flag operation.
And then the mainstream media
reported on what he said
and turned everything into a circus.
The media, Jones said,
created an atmosphere
where nobody knew what the facts were.
So there was no real way
for him to get it right.
Jones and his lawyer argued
that the Sandy Hook parents
were victimized four times,
by the shooter, by truthers,
by politicians, and by everyone
else who took their grief
and weaponized it.
In other words, it wasn't his fault.
Now on cross-examination,
Jones also admitted
that he'd basically
called every major event
of the last decade a false
flag incident engineered
by the government.
And the judge was not
pleased by any of this.
You've probably seen the incendiary clips
of the judge telling Jones
to stop lying under oath.
- You're already under
oath to tell the truth.
You've already violated
that oath twice, today.
- Now the judge admonished Jones
for a number of different things.
The first was telling the
jury that he was bankrupt.
Jones repeatedly testified that
he only makes money selling
prepackaged prepper food
for like an apocalypse.
Everything else was
money-losing that he claimed,
but plaintiffs had already
shown that "Infowars"
was making a lot of money,
as much as $800,000 a day
during certain events.
And one of his employees
testified that the company
makes about $50 million annually.
- That's what the documents says.
- Though faced with three upcoming trials,
Jones and his companies have
started bankruptcy proceedings.
Now when a company files
for chapter 11 protection,
it tends to stay the
other legal proceedings.
Jones has many LLCs,
but the biggest company
is Free Speech Systems.
Free Speech Systems filed
for bankruptcy in Texas.
So Jones's lawyer moved to stay
the Connecticut proceedings,
which is a different case.
But this was the second
delay in the Connecticut case
because of bankruptcy maneuvers.
Back in April, "Infowars"
and two of its subsidiaries,
Infowars Health LLC,
and Prison Planet LLC,
also filed for bankruptcy protection.
Now these entities were
removed as named defendants
so that the damages
proceeding could move forward.
Now Free Speech Systems
listed 14.3 million in assets,
including over a million dollars in cash,
and almost 1.6 million in
property and equipment.
However, the petition claimed
the company had 79 million
in liabilities, including
a $54 million debt owed
to something called PQPR Holdings.
Now who owns PQPR Holdings?
Well it's Carol Jones and David Jones,
also known as Alex Jones' mom and dad.
Now the Sandy Hook plaintiffs
believe the bankruptcy
proceedings are a sham.
Heslin, Pozner, and two
other Sandy Hook families
filed separate lawsuits, accusing Jones
of hiding millions of dollars in assets.
The plaintiff said the $54
million debt was dubious
since PQPR is a Nevada-registered company
that is owned by shell entities
owned by Jones' kids and parents.
There's substantial evidence
of fraudulent transfers.
And it's not even clear
that the bankruptcy court
would discharge the Sandy
Hook judgments anyway.
So while Jones may delay, it's
likely to be a pure victory.
And going back to what
Jones was admonished
for during the trial,
Jones told the jury that he had complied
with the court's discovery orders,
which is absolutely false.
Now, during discovery,
plaintiffs asked for a number
of different things,
but they specifically asked
Jones to identify the number
of videos he produced about Sandy Hook.
Jones and his co-defendants
refused to produce
this material, which is one of the reasons
for the default judgment.
And the plaintiff's lawyer has generally
had a pretty easy time
showing that Alex Jones
was lying about the stuff
that was actually produced.
- Mr. Reynal had told the jury
that there was 29 minutes
total of "Infowars" videos.
He played 51 minutes in a single video.
So, you know that's not true.
He has routinely, every
single day of this trial,
broken rules that a
first-year lawyer knows.
He has routinely placed
inadmissible material
in front of the jury.
It is from our perspective of this table
that Mr. Reynal is actively
trying for mistrial.
- And the judge told Alex Jones's lawyer
to stop many different times.
- I am very upset that you
have tried to imply to the jury
that we know how many videos
about Sandy Hook were released
by your clients when we don't
because they refused to
respond to discovery.
So I do not want you to do that again.
And I don't want you to
argue with me about it.
That is the rule of this case.
That's it, they didn't respond.
We don't know.
We've had multiple
conversations about how I know
you know what the rules are,
and you know you know what the rules are,
but you've chosen not to
follow them on occasion.
- And despite the judge's
very clear instructions
on the number of videos,
Reynal interrupted the judge to argue.
- The number of videos, their length,
this is evidence that is being
introduced in the courtroom.
- Yes, but what you said was not,
"We've shown the jury 29 minutes of clips
where the word Sandy Hook
appears," or anything like that.
It was, "They released
in total 29 minutes."
That is not true.
- The judge made it
extraordinarily clear to Alex Jones
what he could and could not do.
- You may not say to this jury
that you complied with discovery.
That is not true.
You may not say it again.
You may not tell this jury
that you are bankrupt.
That is also not true.
You're already under
oath to tell the truth.
You've already violated
that oath twice, today,
in just those two examples.
It seems absurd to instruct you again,
that you must tell the
truth while you testify,
yet, here I am.
You must tell the truth while you testify.
This is not your show.
You need to slow down
and not take what you see as opportunities
to further the message you
are wanting to further.
And instead, only answer the
specific and exact question
you have been asked.
- Now, what makes all of these exchanges
particularly remarkable is
that Jones's lawyer Reynal
probably knew that there
was a ticking time bomb
that disproved Jones's
claims about discovery.
The ticking time bomb
was that Jones's lawyer
had accidentally sent 300 gigabytes
of unredacted information
directly to plaintiff's counsel.
And that included Jones's
entire cell phone backup.
And sure enough, on cross examination,
a plaintiff's lawyer,
Bankston reminded Jones
that he claimed to have
searched for messages related
to Sandy Hook on his phone.
Jones said yes, that he did
the search, but found nothing.
- So you did get my text messages
and said you didn't?
Nice trick.
- And that led to the Perry
Mason moment where Bankston
absolutely skewered Jones
on cross examination
by pointing out that
these documents did exist
in the form of text messages and emails
that mentioned Sandy Hook.
And the reason that Bankston
knew that they existed
is because Jones's lawyer
accidentally sent him
the entire cell phone.
- I see, I told you the truth.
This is your Perry Mason moment.
- Yeah, that's quite the exchange.
And in fact, I have an
entire video covering
both this Perry Mason moment,
and the equally interesting hearing
that was held the next day
where the defense council
moved for mistrial.
And that also did not
go well for Alex Jones.
But since liability was already conceded,
it didn't really take the jury
very long to award damages
to the plaintiffs.
The jury found that Alex
Jones should pay $4.1 million
in compensatory damages
for repeatedly claiming
the school shooting was a hoax.
Now a court awards compensatory damages
to put the plaintiff in the situation
that they would've been,
had the harm not occurred.
Now compensatory damages
include both economic
and noneconomic damages, such
as medical bills, lost wages,
pain and suffering, mental impairment,
and emotional distress.
Heslin and Lewis were seeking
$150 million from Jones,
but the jury's verdict fell
pretty far short of that mark.
Jones's lawyer, Reynal, asked
jurors to award a total of $8.
$1 for each of the eight
harms the defendants inflicted
on Heslin and Lewis.
Of course, he couldn't ask for nothing
because liability was conceded.
Now the jury's verdict was not unanimous.
Two of the juries did not sign the form.
In Texas, civil jury verdict
does not have to be unanimous.
But that takes us to the punitive damages,
or as Texas calls them, exemplary damages.
Now, a court will award
exemplary damages in Texas
to punish the wrongdoer for
their particularly bad behavior.
Exemplary damages are
also meant to deter people
who might act like the
defendant in the future.
So in other words, Texas exemplary damages
are meant to penalize the
defendant for their behavior
and to warn others not
to do the same thing.
And under section 41.003,
the Texas Code of Practice and Remedies,
exemplary damages are
awarded to a plaintiff
if they prove with clear
and convincing evidence
that they're harm resulted
from fraud, malice,
or gross negligence.
But exemplary damages may only be awarded
if the decision is unanimous.
This, in combination with the
clear and convincing evidence
standard makes it difficult
to recover exemplary damages
in personal injury cases in Texas.
But there's another
wrinkle because in Texas,
there's a statutory
cap on punitive damages
in personal injury cases.
An award of exemplary damages
may not exceed an amount equal
to the greater of two
times the economic damages
plus an amount equal to
any non-economic damages
found by the jury, not to
exceed $750,000 or $200,000.
And another subsection
prohibits telling the jury
about this particular cap.
Now, the reason the
juries are not instructed
is that that might
influence their thinking.
They might shift punitive damages
into the compensatory damages.
So it's entirely possible
that the jury can come up
with a much bigger amount
than the statute allows.
And if a jury returns
an award that is higher
than the statutory cap,
then the judge just
simply reduces the amount.
And in closing arguments, the
plaintiffs attorney argued
that this was the jury's ability
to send a message to quote,
"Stop Alex Jones, stop the monetization
of misinformation of lies."
The defense argued that
Jones had only spent 18 hours
and 43 minutes talking about Sandy Hook,
and that they only made
about $14,000 per hour
during the coverage.
And that should form
the basis of the award.
And following closing arguments,
the jury returned to
verdict of $45 million
in punitive damages.
But given the statutory limits
that we just talked about,
it's likely that the
punitive damages award
is likely to get chopped down to well less
than a million dollars.
But that raises the question
what's next for Alex Jones?
Well, the answer is more trials.
On September 14th, the Pozner
and De La Rosa plaintiffs
will face Jones in Texas courtroom.
In addition, Jones may find
himself in deeper trouble
with the January 6th Committee,
which wants to see all of the information
that was on his cell phone,
which was turned over to
the plaintiff's attorneys.
Jones took the 5th Amendment 100 times
during his testimony to
the January 6th committee.
And in this trial, Judge Gamble said
she would not enter an
order stopping Bankston,
the plaintiff's attorney,
from giving the material to
the January 6th committee.
- I don't know that you
get to stop that anyway.
- Additionally, Jones'
lawyers are in hot water.
Reynal is facing potential discipline
by the Connecticut Bar.
On the same day that the Texas
jury handed down the verdict,
a judge ordered Reynal and
Jones' lawyer, Norm Pattis,
to attend a hearing about
whether they should be referred
to disciplinary authorities or sanctioned
by the court directly
for releasing confidential medical records
in violation of state and federal law,
in the contra of the
court's protective order.
And although Jones told the jury
that any verdict over
$2 million will sink us,
after the verdict, Jones'
lawyer assured reporters
that the verdict meant
Jones would continue
to be on the air,
presumably, profitably for
the foreseeable future.
Now, the other thing that
could be next for Alex Jones
is a perjury conviction.
Many people have pointed
out that it sure seems
like Jones obviously lied
on the stand, AKA, perjury.
And to find out about the law of perjury
and Jones' chances of conviction,
you'll have to head
over to today's sponsor,
Nebula and Curiosity Stream.
On Nebula, my videos always
come out early with zero ads,
and I release exclusive
content all the time,
like this entire video on the implications
of Jones' testimony and
whether it rises to perjury,
as well as exclusive videos,
like things people misunderstand
about the Constitution,
why NFTs are bad for creators,
and my first full length
documentary, "Bad Law Words Good",
and tons more, all exclusive to Nebula.
And all of this exclusive
content is available
only on Nebula, which you can get for free
with Curiosity Stream.
Nebula is creator-owned
and creator-operated.
And there's new exclusive
content released multiple times
every single day.
Oh, and by the way, we've been
developing Nebula like crazy.
It now has apps for iOS,
Android, Apple TV, Roku, Fire TV,
and Android TV.
And it was recently nominated
for its first Streamy Award.
My fellow creators and I
really care about Nebula.
And we're thrilled to be
partnering with Curiosity Stream
because they are the go-to
source for the best documentaries
and long-form educational
content on the internet.
And they even have an
entire section devoted
to unsolved mysteries in crime.
So if you like my videos,
you'll love the thousands of
titles on Curiosity Stream.
Now the best way to get access to Nebula
and all of its incredible content
is through the amazing Curiosity
Stream, Nebula bundle deal
with its current sales price
of less than $15 per year
to get access to both sites.
And to be clear, that Nebula
subscription's not a trial.
It's free for as long as you
are a Curiosity Stream member.
There just isn't a better deal
in streaming where you get
two great streaming sites
with content that you'll
actually watch and enjoy
for less than $15 per year
at its current sales price.
Well, what's more is signing up
will actually help countless
independent educational creators
beyond just Legal Eagle.
So sign up now by clicking on this button
that's here on screen right now,
or you can click on the
link that's down below
in the description.
It's a great way to
support educational content
and get tons of exclusive
content that you'll love.
So click right now.
And after you do that, click
on this playlist over here
for more Legal Eagle videos.
So click here, or I'll see you in court.